urgent ce sont de nouveau auquel on
César pas seulement en réalité ce que
l'Ukraine attend c'est ce dont elle a
des besoins pour compléter et à
commencer les stocks qui sont sans doute
relativement bas on peut imaginer le
besoin de munitions d'artillerie le
besoin de transport le besoin
effectivement de canon César ou autre et
puis tout un tas d'autres choses on a
parlé aussi de batterie antimicile de
système qui permettent de contrer les
incursions russes dans l'espace aérien
bref tout ce qui est
utile et qui peut contribuer à protéger
une ligne de front qui fait comme
quasiment 1000 km est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
la France a encore les capacités de
livrer des armes bien évidemment que
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose et en réalité le problème est moins
de savoir ce que la France peut faire
que ce qui va être aussi directement
utile pour Kiev il y a trois questions
en fait qui se posent c'est de quoi les
soldes ukrainiens ont réellement besoin
le temps et le délai dans lequel on va
aussi pouvoir les former pour qu'il
puisse utiliser ces systèmes et puis
derrière les capacités de maintenance
parce que lorsqu'on parle d'équipement
militaire c'est pas le tout dans l'ivré
c'est que derrière il y a des questions
de main d'oeuvre il y a des questions de
maintenance il y a des questions de
pièces détachées et c'est peut-être ça
en fait en réalité la clé du succès la
capacité à générer à produire du stock
et à durer sur la sur la longue durée le
secteur industriel de l'armement a du
mal à se renouveler c'est pas qu'il ait
du mal à se renouveler c'est que en
réalité pendant des années les mais
c'est la plupart du c'est le cas
finalement pour la plupart des grandes
puissances industrielles on a ignoré la
guerre on a ignoré finalement ce que
pouvait être la haute intensité les
questions du nombre d'obus dont on a
besoin et qui est disponible par exemple
c'est quelque chose que la plupart des
pays
occidentaux ont comme problème quand on
regarde bien la difficulté qu'il y a par
exemple en Ukraine les Ukrainiens tirent
à peu près 5 à 6000 coups par
jour
les
Russes à peu près entre 20 et 25000 et
c'est encore sacrément diminué sachant
que quand vous regardez par exemple sur
les obus de 155 mm l'industrie
américaine en fabrique entre 20 et 30
000 par mois donc c'est à dire que vous
avez des ratios comme ça qui montre bien
que oui on a des difficultés et puis ces
industries d'armement elles sont aussi
mondialisées un exemple pour faire des
obus sans fumée on a besoin de de choses
qui sont en fait finalement liées à un
industrie du coton donc vous avez de la
sécheresse vous avez moins de coton donc
moins de capacités à nourrir ou à
utiliser ça dans vos systèmes d'obus et
puis l'éducation du financement vous me
disiez juste avant de prendre l'antenne
que les systèmes patriotes américains
coûtaient extrêmement cher ben voilà
c'est à dire qu'en fait la guerre de
haute intensité c'est aussi une guerre
de haute finance et que finalement tout
ça on estime que c'est à peu près le
système qui est qui est dit que un
système patriotes un seul système mais
c'est un gros système vous avez des
radars des lanceurs un poste de
commandement tout ça coûte à peu près
effectivement un milliard de dollars
depuis le début de la guerre Emmanuel
Macron est accusé ne pas en faire assez
il y a eu un
rapport de l'Institut qui elle pour
l'économie mondiale un organisme
allemand qui compile les soutiens des
Occidentaux à l'Ukraine et qui estiment
que la France et onzième dans les pays
qui la liste des pays qui livrent des
armes est-ce qu'on a attendait plus de
la part des Français ou est-ce que c'est
un mauvais procès moi je pense que c'est
un mauvais procès je pense que il y a
deux choses qui sont souvent occultées
dans ce genre de sujet c'est d'abord que
la France a commencé à s'engager au côté
des Ukrainiens avant le 24 février 2022
donc c'est à dire qu'il y a des efforts
qui ont été faits d'accompagnement de
formation de de soutien à l'Ukraine
avant le début de de cette deuxième
phase de la guerre puisqu'il faut bien
rappeler que la guerre en Ukraine elle a
commencé en 2014 ça c'est donc la
première chose la deuxième c'est que les
Français ou du moins le gouvernement
français annonce ce qu'il donne et le
donne réellement vous avez aussi
beaucoup de pays et je n'en citerai pas
pour le coup qui eux font l'inverse qui
annonce mais la livraison se fait
attendre voire n'a pas lieu et puis
ensuite là encore quand on évoque le
fait de donner des cadences César on
voit directement ensuite comment et ils
sont en action donc je pense que c'est
un mauvais procès qui est fait à la
France qui tient sans doute aussi
peut-être à quelquefois l'illisibilité
de son message politique mais je crois
que il faut là encore revenir à ce qui a
été dit affirmé la France condamne sans
réserve l'agression russe et de facto le
soutien à l'Ukraine il est la physique
du ministre le montre bien il est sans
ambage avec Poutine mais de toute façon
à un moment un autre la diplomatie c'est
aussi ça on s'est focalisé la semaine
dernière sur les livraisons de système
patriotes américains la Russie a dit que
les Américains étaient deux facto dans
une guerre indirecte où est-ce qui est
où est la ligne rouge pour que les
Occidentaux ne paraissent pas comme des
comédiérants c'est très difficile à dire
parce qu'en fait là encore c'est très
facile pour pour Moscou d'accuser mais
on pourrait dire dans ces cas-là que la
Biélorussie en offrant par exemple une
base arrière pour la manœuvre de troupes
russes est aussi déjà de facto en
kobegence c'est je pense une façon de
mettre la pression sur les opinions
publiques aussi occidentales en leur
disant attention on a encore une nuit
rouge qui pourrait être franchie et
c'est quelque chose qui est une corde
raide sur lesquels les gouvernements
occidentaux et même les États-Unis sont
assez prudents par exemple on livrant un
système patriotes Biden a aussi précisé
qu'il n'y aurait pas de soldats
américains déployés sur
sur le territoire ukrainien donc il
montre bien quand même que il y a quand
même des limites et que on fait
attention à soutenir l'Ukraine à lui
donner les moyens mais sans s'engager de
manière directe effectivement merci
beaucoup Guillaume la sonnerie